all of these characters look like they
really could have participated in the
robot pizza wars of the 1980s in 1983
it's believed that William aton's oldest
son killed his youngest by holding him
up to the mouth of the Freddy Fazbear
animatronics phase the little boy who
was scared of Freddy was crying in fear
his tears caused the spring lock
mechanism to malfunction and Freddy's
mouth to bite down on the boy's head
crushing it this tragedy or one like it
is the cause of afton's murderous and
Psychopathic Tendencies under that
corporate facade lies an egotistical
sadus who doesn't just want to kill
victims but designs their deaths to
ensure that they physically suffer first
it's not about the killing it's about
causing pain in others where the sism
comes from is Up For Debate but many
FNAF scholars believe that Aton was
irreparably changed from the loss of his
son fredbear's Family Diner only stayed
open for a few years after this incident
but just long enough for William Aton to
kill his first known victim Charlotte
Emily the daughter of fredbear family
Diner's co-owner Henry Emily